Delphine 2 Daniel je comprends pas votre
nom moi
je trouve que quand il est là il se
passe quelque chose je mets deux
Géraldine 3 et Guillaume c'est une
escroquerie
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes des fous
vous êtes d'accord avec mes notes ou pas
pour vous pour moi le mercredi avec vous
inclure non moi je suis pas le meilleur
du tout
non moi je suis là alors le meilleur
chroniqueur
[Musique]
je réfléchis vite moi c'est entre
effectivement Gilles et Géraldine
d'accord
[Rires]
toujours sur tous les sujets et il
permet le débat donc
il a 4 sur 5
voilà on est pas là-haut
on mélange de l'eau d'accord
avec lui ben je lui dis toujours bravo
donc je te dis encore une fois bravo et
pour moi c'est vraiment le meilleur
alors pour vous
c'est difficile je vais dire
les mecs abonnez-vous dans quelle
émission on entend un gars qui dit
attention au bus
non mais sans déconner c'est quoi ça
mais la seule émission on entend
attention au bus non mais franchement on
est où là dans les collègues c'est Bison
Futé ou quoi là qui fait l'émission
qui va arriver dans un instant pour
fêter les audiences de ce
saison
non c'est vrai j'aime bien débattre avec
elle elle dit n'importe quoi mais c'est
un
[Applaudissements]
alors quand il est pas fatigué Raymond
il est imbattable je trouve mais comme
il est souvent fatigué je dis
pareil
moi Géraldine parce qu'elles font ça
tient tête elle lâche pas le morceau
pour moi ce côté très fort Guillaume
Raymond mais c'est vrai que Gilles les
structurant pour l'émission parce que
dès que vous lancez sur un truc c'est
lui qui parle c'est lui qui explose
l'effet il est béton sur tous les trucs
judiciaires et en fait nous si on peut
briller aussi c'est grâce à lui il est
tellement de conneries
et toi Didi moi Gilles Verdez parce que
c'est un très bon journaliste parce
qu'on aime lui en mettre plein la gueule
dans la bonne humeur
ça va aussi Batman
en direct on dirait un gars qui va faire
l'amour et dans le pré
c'est un truc de fou